Maybe they can
provide classified material
next year for that.
What were you thinking
Let me get a chance
to speak on all of this.
God willing, soon.
But as I said earlier
this week,
people and by the way,
my Corvette's in a lot garage.
Okay, so it's not like you're si
on the street, but anyway, right
Yes.
As well as my Corvette.
But as I said earlier, this week
people know
I take classified documents
of classified material seriously
I also said we're cooperating fu
complete with the Justice
Department's review
as part of that process.
My lawyers
reviewed other places
where documents in my
of from my time as vice
president were stored,
and they finished the review las
They discovered a small number
of documents
of classified markings and stora
and file cabinets
in my home of my in my
my personal library.
This was done in the case of the
and this was done
in the case of the Biden Pen Cen
The Department of Justice was im
as was done.
notified and
the lawyers
arranged for the Department of J
to take possession of the docume
So if you're going to see
we're going to see all this unfo
I'm confident
Thank you very
First Lady serves as the first l
She's doing really well.
She
she was under a long time
for 5 hours because what they we
is they take out
what do the memos mean and remov
what they thought,
what might be cancerous.
And they'd have to
then go back and test it
and see what it was.
But she's doing really well.
She's up we had
we had breakfast this morning
and she's she's recovering
and she can be sore for a while
because of the work they did on
And for,
you know, that's
where one of these these were.
But she is
00 to 1% chance
of ever return of any cancer.
And so thank God she's doing rea
Thank you for
that.